[MUSIC PLAYING]
CARTER MORGAN: Welcome
to this week's episode
of "VM End to End," where
we have a VM skeptic
and a VM enthusiast come
together and hash out
all things Cloud VMs.
Brian, thanks for being here.
BRIAN DORSEY: Absolutely.
I think today is
networking, right?
CARTER MORGAN: It is
networking, because last time,
you left me off feeling
really good about VMs.
And I'm like, this can't stand.
We've got to go deeper
and figure it out.
So could you tell me, from
a big-picture overview, what
is networking like once
you're using Google's
infrastructure and all that?
BRIAN DORSEY: Yeah.
And honestly, I think this
is one of the main reasons
to consider running a
virtual machine in Google
Cloud, because the traffic
back and forth to the machine
runs mostly across the
network that Google built
to serve traffic for
things like Gmail,
and YouTube, and the like.
So I think that's
the big reason.
CARTER MORGAN: When you say
the network Google built,
that's a very precise
set of terminology.
It sounds like someone actually
picked up tools and built
hardware for this.
BRIAN DORSEY: Yeah, and
ran undersea fiber cable,
and built a whole
bunch of things.
So we've got cables we've
laid and leased space
on other cables, all
to reduce the latency,
because the faster
your information
gets to people, the more--
we've just seen research
that people bounce off
of pages that are slow.
So you want to be fast--
as fast as you can be.
CARTER MORGAN: OK.
So then what's this like for
people that aren't on Google?
Say, what is the network like
taking Google Cloud out of it?
What's it like for
a piece of traffic?
What happens?
BRIAN DORSEY: Yeah.
So if you've got
a machine that's
somewhere in a data center, or
actually even on a home network
somewhere, and somebody
else connects to it,
it'll jump across a bunch of
hops and different routers
and machines on the internet.
And the packet makes its way
there and then makes its way
back.
And we've kind of forgotten what
an amazing piece of technology
this is, the internet itself.
It can route around problems
and get the traffic there.
And it may take a
different route,
depending on how busy
things are and other stuff.
But it does mean
that there is kind
of an unpredictability in
the route and the timing
that that takes.
So there's a certain amount of
variation that happens there.
So one of the things we do is
built out dedicated networking.
And the traffic will come
out of a Google machine,
go across Google's network, and
then pop out somewhere close
to the end user--
still on the public
internet, but fewer
hops between them and
the actual service.
And I think that's the
key benefit, I guess,
both for Google's services
and for yours that run here.
And so I think at a high
level that it comes down
to consistency,
predictability of that.
And then there's
another fun thing
that we'll dig into
here of just some
of these networking pieces
we offer as a service,
rather than a particular piece
of hardware that's doing it.
CARTER MORGAN: I've
heard of software
as a service and
infrastructure as a service.
I've never heard of
networking as a service.
What does this mean, Brian?
BRIAN DORSEY: Yeah.
So the industry term for it is
software-defined networking.
And the networks
that your VMs see
are an entirely
software-defined thing
and running on top of
the networking fabric
that runs the data center.
So we've got this
extremely high-speed,
well-interconnected
physical network.
And we run a software-defined
network on top of that.
And that allows things like
firewalls and load balancers
to be provided, like again,
this slice of a data center,
instead of a slice of
a particular computer.
The data center is the
firewall and the data center
is the load balancer.
CARTER MORGAN: A firewall is a
box that you plug in between--
wait, so what do you mean the
firewall is a data center?
BRIAN DORSEY: Yeah.
So instead of a box that you
plugin one side of the network
and the other side of
the network, the firewall
that you're using for
your VMs, and for deciding
what ports are open,
and that sort of thing,
there are a set of rules.
And then instead of
those rules going
to one box that's in
between, the implementation
of the software-defined network
itself enforces those rules.
And that's distributed
across the whole data center.
CARTER MORGAN: And
so instead of having,
oh, my box can't
handle more, Google
can handle all of this for you.
So you get firewall at scale--
firewalls at scale.
BRIAN DORSEY: Exactly.
And where that becomes
really important
is the load balancer at scale.
And it seems really
counterintuitive.
So instead of a particular
box that traffic hits
and it spreads it
around to a whole bunch
of backend machines, right?
CARTER MORGAN: Right.
BRIAN DORSEY: Again,
you're setting rules.
But still, it provides
this endpoint.
It provides one IP address that
you see and routes the traffic
to all of them.
But there's not just
one box doing it.
CARTER MORGAN: I need
to know how this works,
because this is what Google--
like Gmail, YouTube
uses all this.
BRIAN DORSEY: Exactly.
CARTER MORGAN: How?
BRIAN DORSEY: And in fact, we're
configuring those same load
balancers.
And luckily for us, Google
published a paper about this.
And the infrastructure
is called Maglev.
So let's put a link to
that paper down below.
But at a really high level,
it allows multiple computers--
an arbitrary number of
them, so you can just
keep adding them--
to all implement
the same exact
load-balancing rules in sync
so that when you
change the rules or one
of your backend machines
needs to go offline,
you bring a different one
up, all of the load balancing
cluster, essentially,
handles that for you.
And there's distributed hashing
and a bunch of neat stuff
that makes that possible
that's listed in that paper.
CARTER MORGAN: You're
giving me homework.
I got to go read about this now.
So this last episode, we touched
on networking a little bit
and you brought up
Managed Instance Groups,
if I'm correct.
BRIAN DORSEY: Yep.
CARTER MORGAN: This
is the technology
that makes that possible.
BRIAN DORSEY: Yeah.
So Managed Instance
Groups, I think,
are the next level
on top of that.
So once you've got the
ability to route traffic
to a whole bunch of
different computers,
how do you figure
out which computers,
and whether they're working,
and that sort of thing?
That's where Managed Instance
Groups come into play.
CARTER MORGAN: OK.
And so something I keep
hearing just repeatedly,
everyone says global.
Global.
Google has a global network.
I don't necessarily
know what that means.
Can you help clarify?
BRIAN DORSEY: Yeah.
And I guess I made the claim
that your Managed Instance
Group could have machines that
are spread around the globe,
right?
CARTER MORGAN: Right.
BRIAN DORSEY: So at some
level, it means exactly that.
So our network--
we've put down fiber,
and we have data
centers that are
in lots of different
places, and really
fast, as fast as possible.
You still have
light speed there.
CARTER MORGAN:
There are physics.
BRIAN DORSEY: But as fast
as possible interconnect
between them.
And I think the key
concepts to take away
as you're planning your
system is that we group
things in a hierarchy.
So at the top,
you've got global,
an IP address that
could be accessed
from anywhere in the world.
And then regional,
which might be
something like Europe
or North America
or Asia, something like that.
And then zonal.
And conceptually, that's
kind of like a data center.
It's at least a interconnected
set of hardware--
machines, networking,
power, redundancy--
that is all one unit.
And the idea is that, if there
is a failure in one zone,
it shouldn't affect
another zone.
So you can choose to put
things in different zones
and trust that they're unlikely
to have the same issue that
affects each other.
CARTER MORGAN: OK.
So then you get data redundancy
and backups, all of that,
from zones.
BRIAN DORSEY: Yeah.
So that's how you build
reliability into your system
so that you can keep
things separate.
And the Managed Instance
Group can cross those.
And it's really useful.
And I think one key
thing to just keep
in the back of your head
is that communication
tends to be faster within
a zone and cheaper.
CARTER MORGAN: Things
are closer together.
BRIAN DORSEY: And it
takes a little extra time
and costs a little more
money to cross between zones.
CARTER MORGAN: I
think at this point,
we've talked about
high-level benefits
of using Cloud's networking.
I can't poke any holes
in the argument just now.
It looks like it's very
useful for VM users.
But I know that can't
be all of the benefits.
So what I'm curious about, what
are the other core concepts?
We've talked high level.
Are there any lower level
concepts that you're
like, this is really cool?
BRIAN DORSEY: Yeah.
So we've already talked about
firewalls, load balancers,
that sort of thing, which
implies public IP addresses.
But I think there's
a couple of other,
I don't know, just
words, like terminology,
that we should talk about a bit.
CARTER MORGAN: What you got?
BRIAN DORSEY: And one of
those is VPC networks.
And then the other
concept is how
you connect to these
networks from other places.
CARTER MORGAN: OK.
I hear virtual private
cloud all the time.
I'm confused, because I thought
that's what a Google Cloud
network--
BRIAN DORSEY: Cloud is?
CARTER MORGAN: Yeah.
What is Virtual Private Cloud?
BRIAN DORSEY: I think
in this context,
it's easiest just to think of
it as the collection of services
that provide networking for us.
So a VPC network is a security
boundary, if you will.
It's the name of
our networking bits.
CARTER MORGAN: So everything.
BRIAN DORSEY: So
kind of everything.
But to be more concrete, since
that's kind of vague, when
you create a project and you
create a VM, by default, there
is a network that is created.
And so we just call that
the default network.
And it provides private,
nonroutable IP addresses.
So the public internet is all on
the main pool of IP addresses.
And there's a couple pools that
are never meant to be routed.
So routers will never send them
across the public internet.
So we use one of those, the
10-dot series of networks,
as a default and
expose that to you.
And all of your VMs, by
default, live on that network,
wherever they are.
So whatever zone
they're in, they're
all on the same 10-dot network.
CARTER MORGAN: Oh wow.
So I can just address them
like they're right next to me
everywhere?
What about-- OK, here's
an interesting one.
So if I have a VPC, and
you have a VPC, 10.1.1--
is that shared?
Or do we get our
own separate one?
BRIAN DORSEY: Yeah.
So that is a nonroutable
private address space,
so you can't ever have
collisions with other people.
And my 10.1.1.1 will be
different than yours.
And the things will never
move across that way.
CARTER MORGAN: That simplifies
a lot of networking.
BRIAN DORSEY: Yes.
CARTER MORGAN: OK.
I want to be
skeptical but that--
OK.
BRIAN DORSEY: OK, so let
me add one onto that.
CARTER MORGAN: Yes.
BRIAN DORSEY: Another
thing along those lines
is that when you create a
VM, you give it a hostname.
And we automatically
provide DNS of name lookup
based on those names
for all the machines.
So you can just ping
another VM by its hostname
wherever it is in the
world, in whatever network,
and it just simplifies a
lot of things in automation.
CARTER MORGAN: Yeah, OK.
What about if I wanted to bring
on my own IP address, so public
IP address?
Because this is all private.
Is there a way to do that?
BRIAN DORSEY: Yes.
Yep.
There sure is.
And so we have both this concept
of ephemeral IP addresses.
So if you just make
a machine and say,
I want to have a
public IP address,
and I don't care what
it is, you can do that.
And then most of the
time, you actually want
a kind of long-lived
address so that maybe you
can give it a DNS entry
and make it mywebsite.com,
instead of a series of numbers.
And those can be either
attached to a particular VM when
you startup--
and if you just have one
computer, that's handy.
But often, you actually attach
it to the load balancer.
And the load balancer becomes
that long-lived, stable
endpoint, and the machines
come and go behind the scenes.
CARTER MORGAN:
OK, that's smooth.
So how do I get
started with this?
How do I take--
say I have something,
an on-prem system.
I want to connect to
Google Cloud's network.
How do I do this?
BRIAN DORSEY: Yeah.
So I'll take that in two phases.
So getting started, the
networking is there by default.
And then you add the pieces as
you need them-- rules, or load
balancers, or what have you.
But this connectivity
bit, that's interesting.
So the main one I
talked about so far
is via the public internet.
And we try to get off the
internet as quick as we can,
but things are
routed across there.
And that's using just the
normal wide-open protocol.
So you may want to
use something that's
encrypted these days, that
sort of thing, if you can.
But it's running across
the public internet.
Usually, that's not what people
want when you think about,
hey, I want to connect
my servers to the Cloud.
And so we have a couple of
different ways of doing that.
One is setting up a VPN,
a Virtual Private Network.
And we have a hosted
IPsec VPN termination.
So you can use the
IPsec protocol, using
whatever hardware or
software you have,
and connect that to
the Cloud network.
And then your
machine's on one end
and your Cloud machines can
just talk to each other,
as if they're on
the same network.
CARTER MORGAN: And then you said
that was two of the main ones.
There's another?
BRIAN DORSEY: And
then there's another.
So that's still running
across the public internet,
but encrypted.
So it's safe, but
occasionally, you
have a use case where you
need to get the latency down
as low as you possibly can.
And there's nothing that
really beats co-location.
You put the machines in
the same places, right?
So we have something called
Cloud Interconnect that allows
you to get rackspace in--
CARTER MORGAN:
Inside a warehouse?
BRIAN DORSEY: --a
hosting provider.
Well, inside a hosting
provider that we
have a connection with or
with partners who do the same.
And so you get
right there, where
the network's terminated, and
never leave their private data
centers.
CARTER MORGAN: All right, Brian.
I got to be honest.
It's getting hard to be
skeptical at this point.
You're doing a good job.
It sounds cool.
I guess I have-- if I had
to ask one last question,
it's going to sound
like a gotcha,
but I don't mean it to be.
What are the advantages
or why would someone
want to work at this level,
the infrastructure level,
over working at, say,
the Kubernetes level?
Where I could still work
with the Cloud load balancer,
but a lot of choices
have been made.
I don't have to deal with
all the nitty-gritty.
BRIAN DORSEY: Yeah.
And there's some
real big advantages
to having a curated experience.
Kubernetes sets a
bunch of stuff up.
It handles authentication
even between the connections
and gives you these
nice abstractions.
And so you get this
endpoint you can connect to.
So if you're already
running a cluster,
I think you should
keep doing that.
That said, there's
a lot of apps that
just don't run in Kubernetes,
maybe yet or maybe ever.
And sometimes, you want to use
a lot of these same patterns.
And I think this static endpoint
of a load balancer in front of,
even if it's just one
machine, is actually
a very useful pattern.
And so I think it's worth
keeping that in mind.
There's a few
additional options.
I don't think those
are super key.
But I think this compatibility
with other things that
are going on-- if you've
got a bunch of services
in Kubernetes, and you want
to add a few more that are not
in Kubernetes, it's really
useful to be able to do that.
And then I think what we
talked about earlier, where
sometimes you have a system
that just doesn't have
as many moving parts and
you don't necessarily
want to setup a whole cluster to
do that, it's a really nice way
to get similar patterns
with way less complexity.
CARTER MORGAN: That
makes a lot of sense.
And I like what you
said about Kubernetes
as a curated approach to Cloud.
You don't always want
or need that curation.
And so it sounds like
working at this level,
you get a lot of great power--
great power.
You get power.
You get flexibility.
And that comes with
responsibility.
So if you're a strength
trainer or a Yogi,
know that you have
responsibilities.
BRIAN DORSEY:
Actually, exactly that.
And I want to just riff
on that for a moment.
I think that concept
you described
there is true across the VMs.
So you get a little
more control and you
have to do a little
more, or you can kind of
work up the layers, if
that's the right fit for you.
CARTER MORGAN: Right.
This is why I like
talking with you, Brian.
We riff, and it
makes me very happy.
Thinking of these
riffs in the future
and why I think we
should do this again,
you said you want to talk
about security in the future.
So let's definitely do that.
What else do we
need to talk about?
BRIAN DORSEY: Yeah.
I think the next thing
I want to talk about,
just because I'm so excited
about them, is the disks.
I want to go into more
detail about how they work
and what extra
capabilities they give you
that you might not
be thinking of.
CARTER MORGAN: You
really love disks.
BRIAN DORSEY: I do.
CARTER MORGAN: You know what?
All right.
Next episode, why don't
we talk about disks?
BRIAN DORSEY: Let's do it.
CARTER MORGAN: All right.
Well, y'all, thank you all for
listening and checking this
out.
Brian, you're slowly but
surely convincing me.
I'm not happy to admit
it, but here we are.
Thank you again for
coming in and talking.
BRIAN DORSEY: Thank you much.
See you all next episode.
[MUSIC PLAYING]